Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy here to discuss with you a
strange and little noted phenomenon the
global outbreak of mental illness
recently a Muslim screaming Allah abbar
an Infidel you must die stabbed four
people killing one of them at a train
station near Munich nevertheless
Bavarian security officials immediately
denied that he had what they called an
Islamic extremist motive then what did
cause the attack Bavaria State interior
Minister Joakim Herman said that the
attacker had mental disorders here you
are nothing to do with Islam don't go
jumping at conclusions that these
stabbings had something to do with Islam
just because he screamed Akbar and
Infidel you must die he was mentally ill
that's all in fact we have seen this
kind of mental illness before there here
are some headlines and key lines from
some recent news news articles that all
show a global outbreak of mental illness
France Muslim destroys Christmas
decorations screams Allah Akbar from the
article his mental state quickly found
wanting required his placement in the
Specialized Hospital alone France Muslim
driver ramming pedestrians while
screaming Akbar was absolutely not an
act of terrorism and from that article
this is absolutely not an act of
terrorism said prosecutor Marie
Christine terrar told reporters during a
press conference adding that the man had
a longlasting and severe psychological
disorder and had been hospitalized over
15 times since
2002 another UK Imam accused of
recruiting for Jihad group doesn't have
to wear electronic tag it breaches his
human rights and the article explains a
terror suspect last night won a human
rights case to have his tag removed
because he thinks MI5 has put a bomb
inside it a judge said the dangerous
preacher of hate has mental health
problems and wearing the electronic
monitoring device was making him
delusional one from California Muslim
arrested in mosque vandalism and from
the article his older sister describes
Khan as having
schizophrenia Muslim NYPD cop killer
told passers by to watch the article
says the gunman who fatally ambushed two
New York City police officers in their
squad car had a long criminal record a
hatred for police and the government and
an apparent history of mental
instability that included an attempt to
hang himself a year ago police said
Sunday one from France Muslim who
stabbed Rabbi gets four years hadush was
deemed unfit to stand trial because of
mental issues following a psychiatric
evaluation Toronto Muslim charged with
carrying concealed meat cleaver into
Parliament RCMP commissioner Bob pson
told reporters that Ali is known to
authorities but not in the sort of
counterterrorism context in fact Paulson
does not believe that the man's actions
were politically motivated or an act of
Terror I understand it is less a concern
around so-called National Security
considerations as it is a mental health
issue he said there is a history of
behaviors that are odd Austria Muslim
drives car into crowd killing three then
gets out and stabs passers by police are
not currently investigating terrorism as
a motive and the man is believed to be
suffering from mental illness
Canada police shoot Muslim wearing a
parent suicide vest and holding
triggering device in the aftermath of
the shooting police downplayed the
incident saying that only that the call
involved an emotionally disturbed
person Muslim bangs on cockpit door
threatens to down plane wanted to see
Allah La after being held back from the
cabin door which could not have been
opened anyway the man who fellow
passengers and said appeared to have
mental health issues was then guarded by
staff and the sports stars in business
class muslima who beheaded toddler
recently became religious started
wearing hijab one theory is that the
woman is mentally ill and that she may
have been exploited by a man or men she
knew Canada Ottawa Shooter's father
waged Jihad in Libya in 2011 shooter not
a recent convert but a longtime Muslim
Michael zoff bibo the slain 32-year-old
suspected killer of a Canadian Forces
Soldier near Parliament Hill was a
laborer and smalltime criminal a man who
had had a religious Awakening and seems
to have become mentally
unstable Canada Muslim acting in the
name of Allah runs down two soldiers
flips car after Chase charges officers
with long knife and is shot and the
article says we are at the beginning of
an investigation several hypotheses are
being looked at said Sergeant Michelle
brune adding that investigators would
study various angles including mental
illness and terrorism Philly cop shooter
I follow Allah I pledge my allegiance to
the Islamic State that is why I did what
I did from the article Archer's mother
has indicated that he is mentally ill
and Ross said investigators do not know
yet if the suspect was indeed
radicalized or tied to
terrorism Oklahoma school evacuated
after Middle Eastern woman says she came
there to take the kids to heaven during
the news conference police also said
that the woman had been having mental
health concerns
recently Chattanooga Jihad murderer
viewed alaki material online spoke of
Islamic martyrdom as long ago as
2013 as the FBI sent more investigators
into the city Monday to explore dozens
of possible leads a picture took shape
of a deeply troubled young man who
struggled with mental illness and drug
abuse at the same time he found himself
alienated from United States policies in
the Arab world according to the
authorities friends and the family
representative Colorado Muslim stabs cop
drops Quran during struggle at about 2
p.m. Saturday the suspect's family told
law enforcement that they were worried
because Clark left his residence in
Penrose and said he wasn't going to
return they also said Clark was mentally
Disturbed had been working out a great
deal during the last two months and
recently had broken up with his
girlfriend
New York City Police Commissioner
Hatchet attack by convert to Islam was
Terror but the article says authorities
also are trying to determine if Thompson
had any history of mental illness UK
Muslim admitted sharing Jihad videos
rants about enemy of Islam Court Ahmed
who has a history of mental health
problems pleaded guilty to two counts of
dissemination of a terrorist publication
France Muslim screaming Allah abbar
tries to strangle police officer other
police officers saw the events on the
video surveillance system and rushed to
save their colleague who had been thrown
to the ground his asent was said to have
a history of psychiatric problems Spain
violent Muslims screaming Allah abbar
all you Christians will die gets
arrested the article says later he was
administered comprehensive tests to
ascertain if he was under the influence
of drugs or suffer Ed from a mental
illness UK Muslim gets 20 years for
trying to set up Jihad training camp in
Oregan harun aswat who has been treated
for mental illness in the UK had pleaded
guilty to the charge in March after
being extradited from Britain to the US
last year France knife wielding Muslim
teen screams Allah abbar shoots teacher
with BB gun a psychiatric examination
was scheduled for October 13th with the
when the te when the te with the
teenager likely to be brought before a
judge Colorado muslima pleads guilty to
conspiring to Aid the Islamic State
Moore set sentencing for January 23rd
saying he wanted time for Conley to
undergo more complete psychiatric
testing I desire more information on her
mental state he said asking for both a
psychological and personality
evaluation are you starting to see a
pattern what could account for This
Global outbreak of mental illness that
always manifests itself in similar ways
authorities should start asking
themselves why so very many mentally ill
people Embrace Islamic Jihad violence
this sort of thing happens so often that
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders should consider adding
Islamic Jihad as a mental illness in its
next Edition forget about global warming
what are Barack Obama and John KY and
the Learned counterterror analysts of
North America and Europe doing about
this C ious epidemic of mental illness
I'm Robert
Spencer